salut à toi fan de bande annonce
aujourd'hui avec filmsactu je te propose
d'en survolé trois et de s'arrêter sur
des passages où quelques détails vous
ont peut-être échappé il y aura tout
d'abord le trailer du labyrinthe de la
birane de cours non mais deux c'est un
chiffre c'est comme richard iii mais il
n'y a pas eu de richard 2 bref vous la
dire 1 2
suivi des premières images du biopic sur
steve jobs et enfin le tout nouveau
testament de benoît poelvoorde le
labyrinthe de d'abord je vous resituer
dans l'action un jeune homme du nom de
thomas était coincé dans son ami rentes
ou poulets sortis
oui le sortit pas le gentil labyrinthe
genre fleurs et lapin blanc plutôt le
labyrinthe genre sow a joué un jeu alors
qu'il fonçait en est ressorti il apprend
qu'il est dans un labyrinthe beaucoup
plus grand rêve de parole images n'as tu
pas envie de comprendre envie de
comprendre quoi comment tout ça est
arrivé
mais avant j'ai une question de quel
côté est tué quelque chose arrêtes tu es
sûr de rien qui vous ont menti c'est pas
y vas tu es tu sais que ça ne sent pas
très bon quand peter velits je te
propose une alliance
d'ailleurs pour les fans de game of
thrones vous aurez noté la présence d'un
autre acteur de la série ici voilà pour
le labyrinthe de à venir à 2 qui doit
finir oui bon sont maintenant sur steve
jobs ou sow jobs way c'est parti bande
annonce je vous la met en accéléré les
vous allez voir on comprend quand même
l'essence du propos
trois remarques sur cette bande annonce
la première bien ce sont les banques qui
se resserre autour du personnage pendant
qu'il parle
notez-bien convoi fois son visage alors
qu'on en meure dans le vif en marketing
power deuxième remarque la présence de
françois d'avenir sur le lieu de
tournage juste ici troisième remarque le
sentiment d'être un concert de patrick
bruel à la fin de la vendeurs gardent
regardons jeu de plaisir d'entendre un
peu car ce sont pas gays si vous en
faites
bref voilà poursuivi didier passons
maintenant à l'ultime bande annonce de
cette vidéo avec le tout nouveau
testament de benoît poelvoorde extrait
par la droite
la bâloise tu te les déjà dit ça m'agace
à temps
donc voilà après morgan freeman dans
bruce tout-puissant notre cher benoît
incarne dieu il en est pas un portrait
assez surprenant puisqu'il est marié à
une des chiens il a une fille gothique
et il est alcoolique
on a quand même frisé la célèbre phrase
papa c'est quoi cette bouteille de lait
bon il ne changera certainement en bière
ceci est mon sang c'est la fin de cette
vidéo continue d'aller au cinéma mais
n'oubliez pas de venir jeter un oeil sur
youtube de temps en temps allez ciao